she deserves to be on the pyramid she is
in the grip of a Cohen 19 so I just
wanted to tell you that I like you a lot
actually so are you gonna leave like
every other average what I like door hey
yo thanks my sister's boyfriend would
look good in what I want someone to take
me out like on a date or what's a gun
surprise me but then I go and eat ice
cream and cheese
routine okay miss Miller sicko told you
not that Brooke sorry Abby give me
another time
are you attract Weiner or what I'm sorry
don't tell my mom give me another chance
give me another chance
I never said yes you know certainly no I
didn't take back lesson
I said Brooke is your mother so at the
bottom yeah dad
you've got to stop going down to the
grocery store coming back quite a bit
you're also a mom mom you're making this
food you're making us happy
we enjoyed I am live at the top there's
people more deserve
[Music]
who's most likely to get arrested who's
the craziest who's the most popular who
gets the most attention from other guys
who's the best answer
[Music]
[Music]
who's the worst driver who spends the
most money who will have kids first who
will get married first who has the
better style things literally everyone
has done before and if you've never done
it then you're a freak
taking out your phone to check the time
then actually forgetting to check the
time asking what even though you heard
exactly what the person said saying ow
when someone hits you even though it
didn't even hurt
spelling out Wednesday as Wed nest day
this is a perfect opportunity for my
little Kendall
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys so we have made the executive
decision that we are gonna take over the
hype house and rename it and cause the
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys so I'm on my way to go see my
old dance studio for the first time in
like five years
Hey okay so there's people inside but
like I really would die to go inside one
last goodbye oh yeah please kind of give
me you were fifth in the competition
you're fifth on the pyramid she did a
good job you should have watched the
movie Hotel movies it was good well if
you're so good you don't really need to
be a part of the Abby Lee dance company
their picture back up she deserves to be
on the pyramid she is in the group dance
so Jojo came outside to exercise most
people next as I real like Nike or Under
Armour adidas right know the luggage
Jojo she has all that Gucci hoodie
Gucci's pants and Louboutin Jojo what
are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
this is the water a lot of water
oh what a water all over water this is a
what I've got a lot in common the gum
this is a one this is Ayano Oh what I
got a what I got her oh my gum this is a
gum
[Music]
[Music]